euh, il donne juste un peu plus bas,
je vais te le dire, je vais te
dire ce que tu dois faire,
je ne sais pas où sont les deux dames
maintenant, je pense qu'elles sont plus proches du
Buffalo ou quoi,
oh ici, mais
et elles étaient  en regardant maintenant
de près,
vous faites un
euh
ok, zoomez ok,
ils aiment faire une course de plus comme ça s'il vous
plaît
mais c'est 100 fois trop rapide de toute façon,
oh tout de suite mais je veux dire, je veux qu'ils
s'habituent à nous,
spécial
ok, la
curiosité étrangère
c'est  je rétrécis
moi-même
et le tracteur avec le
ok ici et bien prenons
20 secondes de ça,
attendons qu'ils retournent au travail,
d'accord, ils
ne fonctionnent pas,
merci, vous l'
avez déjà fait, ouais, ok,
vous êtes sûr, ok,
ok,
alors on fait quelques gros plans sur le  euh sur
les divers éléments aussi euh euh ah eh
bien euh
tu peux essayer on va s'arrêter
ici essayer de faire un gros plan stop stop stop
stop stop
euh
c'est très sympa parce qu'il y a aussi un gars là qui
travaille avec eux
eh
bien  Je pense que tu peux faire un meilleur
gros plan maintenant
tu dois être plus proche
tu dois être plus proche oui
nous nous rapprochons
dans le cadre
juste oh
ouais
quoi de neuf ok ok
étranger étranger
étranger
ok
ok qu'aimerais-tu faire épisode de Peter
ok mais sûrement
Edition
ils sont tournés vers la liste
donne-le
bien ici on devrait arrêter de tourner et
avoir un tu sais un
plan droit du désert tu sais les
phoques et le désert ils sont comme
là oui un statique mais c'était beaucoup
mieux parce que nous pouvions voir le désert là-
bas, il
y avait plus de déserts de ce côté la plupart des
épisodes
ok nous pouvons continuer notre cercle si tu
veux mais
ok je pense que
jepense
ouais
courir plus haut un peu de neige euh
10 secondes
minutes étrangères
hé arrête d'enregistrer  étranger étranger
un autre McDonald's
oh ouais ok ok oh
bonjour
ok eh bien
faisons-le, peu importe ce que tu
vas faire hé
toujours
accro
étranger
tiens au
destin étranger
mais Asie
oui
euh
attends 20 secondes
donc on a une chance
ok
ok on a ça  tir ok
hein
euh
Centre
oh non essaie de garder le premier essaye de
garder le premier
ok plus près et garde les trois puissances que
tu connais alignées comme ça
ok il y en a un autre qui arrive
ok